Britain's Prime Minister's admitted that
the country will not be able to leave
the EU with a deal in place by the March
29th deadline in a statement outside 10
Downing Street Theresa May pointed a
finger firmly at Parliament for the
chaos two years on MPs have been unable
to agree on a way to implement the UK's
withdrawal as a result we will now not
leave on time with a deal on the 29th of
March this delay is a matter of great
personal regret for me so let's take a
step back to where this brexit cycle
began this week now it follows a letter
sent by Theresa May to Donald Tusk
requesting and asking for an official
brexit extension now the letter clearly
shows that with just nine days to go to
where supposedly leaving the European
Union that deadline would be nigh on
impossible to ratify a deal
constructively so now June the 30th is
what the Prime Minister really wants and
now responding to that request Donald
Tusk has suggested the request would is
probably get backing for the rest of the
EU 27 leaders on one condition
that being that tourism is twice
rejected deal finally gets backing from
across the house in Parliament I believe
that a short extension will be possible
but it will be conditional on a positive
vote on the restore agreement in the
House of Commons so if those conditions
are not met while grexit in that case is
still just nine days away now back here
in Westminster though Theresa May has
received an array of backlash for her
decision to request a delay all she's
doing is running down the clock after a
second heavy defeat today mr. speaker
marks 1,000 days since the referendum
and this government has led the country
and themselves into crisis chaos and
division so now all eyes are on the EU
and Britain in the summit on Thursday
and Friday of this week to try and break
the deadlock that has defined the last
1000 days here in Britain of course
nobody really anticipated we'd still be
in a deadlock
still across the house and the public
Division is really the word that
encapsulates the sentiments across the
house international history professor
Islands spread think stories amazed
taken a huge gamble here by effectively
threatening Parliament I think she
believes that if you write to the last
minute
and it looks as if the only alternative
is no deal then her opponents will
collapse but of course many of our
opponents in the RG don't want a deal
they want no deals so they become happy
for the deal to fail the fact remains
that she'd ago she ated a dreadful deal
most people don't like it most people
think it's not at a bit of interest the
public are against it everyone's against
it except her because this deal is all
in favor of Brussels and does nothing
for the United Kingdom if the as I say
if the speaker allows the deal to come
back if it does come back I think it'll
fail again then should be refused the
short extension and I mean I at that
stage the European Union might just say
well goodbye it's no deal
you